sponges are strange creatures aside from
being some of the oldest extant species
on earth these invertebrates have an odd
way of maintaining rigidity in their
bodies glass sponges have hard
structures within their bodies called
spicules intricate forms made from
amorphous silica that grow and branch to
form wicked shapes researchers looked
into how the sponge forms these highly
symmetrical structures and how they
become so complex under the microscope
spicules from three different kinds of
sponges all have the same crystalline
scaffold made of proteins even though
this basic structure is the same across
species
the spicules then take many different
shapes such as pointing needles branch
trees or spiked spheres looking inside
using x-ray nano tomography gives us a
clue into how spicules develop these
internal scans show that crystalline
protein threads inside the spicules
known as axial filaments predetermine
the shape of the growing spicule
while all modern ways for humans to make
glass involve large amounts of heat it
turns out sponges don't need this
because the spicules grow the glass
along the filaments whose structure is
determined by the protein crystal
branching and it's folding which is a
biological process based on how amino
acids in the protein chain interact with
each other the sponges don't need high
temperatures to generate these fine
structures this biological process is
similar to experimental technologies
just making their way into manufacturing
for solar cells and other electronics so
with a little more research
these ancient sponges could make very
modern technologies easier to produce
[Music]